this topic is measured okay alright this
strain is called measurement we're
getting introduction to this even though
we've been doing measurement for a long
time but just like the whole general
forces trying to do we're trying to make
Brown this as much as one be as
practical as possible so as soon as you
measure things no matter what it is that
you are measuring with right or no
matter what it is that you're actually
measuring you encounter this problem of
accuracy in fact in sort of blankets
learn an aside here I'd like you to
write the brackets accuracy because
significant figures are about us
wrestling with this problem of path so
this number 24 million people make a
guess as to why this might be a
significant important number I should
say to us it is roughly speaking the
population of Australia now it would be
mostly for us unrealistic to think oh
they are exactly 24 million people not
to be familiar one not 22 million 1999
exactly 24 million people in the country
why would it be
and notice it's approximate wife how do
you know that yeah very good
so yeah Australia is a big enough
country that every day every hour maybe
even every minute someone is being born
someone enhancing passing away or even
let's be less less morose than that
people are entering the country and
people are leaving the country right so
this number is constantly changing
that's the first thing I notice okay so
maybe I want to write that down
this number is constantly changing so
therefore even if I had an exact number
in fact I do have an exact number which
I'm gonna write down and I know this
number looks very different but I'll
explain why it is in a second even if we
did have an exact number for the
population not so much like what
planning could you do with the exact
with the exact no but were you familiar
what about whatever it up versus what
planning you can do with the approximate
number that would make a huge difference
probably not that much when you're
working on these scales that's the
fussiest history changing but secondly
how do we arrive at this number
for example that second number there it
was was an exact number for the
population of Australia how do you think
people found that as much as anyone
yeah we did the census in fact amazing
the reason this number is smaller is
because this was the 2011 census okay
yeah how I actually don't what we should
find out I should look up we're gonna
look at something census data in
topic is it yeah it was every five is
this yeah
so obviously should point out what is it
that we wait like and don't do a census
all the time it's a pain it's also
incredibly expensive right if any of you
remember when this happened everyone has
to get a big huge form everyone is do
exactly the same time because otherwise
this is causes promise bars okay so
therefore Bay that this instrument that
we've got a census to get exact number
is difficult to use this is actually a
2016 estimate where do you think this
number comes from if it's not from
census just what do you think
yeah yeah yeah very good
so but I just before we we get into a
new point this is this is actually
primarily the way this is done and we'll
talk about the book about the details of
how but you look at we've got 2011
census we've got censuses censuses since
I yeah okay you've got all of this data
that gives you kind of like a pack right
you get a trend and we saw that in
linear relationships sometimes have a
super consistent trend it's clearly not
going to be that consistent for
something as volatile as population but
you look back right and what you do is
you project an estimate now we know
because there are all these crazies and
variables that we can't ever move finely
detailed we know that this is going to
be close but as a measurement instrument
like this as a measurement instrument
it's a little bit blunt it's not that
detailed and so that's why they don't
say pretty four million and three
hundred thousand is 92 or whatever news
they just say look that's roughly it
that's about as accurate it was a winner
okay kid were you gonna suggest another
point how I was just gonna say yeah look
at the previous censuses yep and just
try and determine a trend and work from
them yeah very good so maybe like their
populations increasing but maybe it's
slowing down so we try and knock that
out these actors so they seem fine okay
so so therefore I know that enjoys
problem between object like this and
something like this this kind of thing
here right where we're seeing is all the
form I would use these reviews a lot
communities of imagery
ninth of August wonderful that's very
soon so all of your hassles are going to
get a good package is moving somewhat
large negative a large now since this is
still filled with very fine detail you
okay but impractical to use so therefore
we resort to things like this now
because you've used one of these before
you guys know roughly how accurate you
can measure something with this right
what's the closest like a measurement
that you can get this it's about one
degree it's supposed to be one degree
but of course if you want to get more
accurate than that you can sigh and say
well maybe it's got a half a degree or
the point is that in every measuring
instrument you've got inaccuracies are
kind of built-in right so therefore I'm
gonna say look I don't really know
exactly so I'm just gonna tell you
roughly and that's what significant
figures are about okay so if you've got
another coming back right how many
significant figures are in this number
what have numbers and the answer is two
of them right so this is two two
significant yes that's a great question
so let me let me push on this because we
need to want to think about this
carefully right just two significant
figures and I'm gonna just treat it as
the same number right if I say 24
million as what or if I see 24 and I see
the numbers there okay again I think if
we saw this number it would be highly
suspicion we didn't we see really is it
exactly that we can't know and that's
going to be the exact number so we can
really assume that there are two
significant figures does that make sense
now let's think about some other example
so who's gonna keep going down the ball
run a think through this and then I'm
gonna let you guys have a go at the
examples yourself if I said to you okay
now don't shout it inside just to think
about that okay if I said to you all
right I have a class not this one
because if it's more shame you show me
close and I cannot but I write down
Betty students just pause for a second
how many significant figures babe this
is interesting is it percent three
percent three uh-huh
this is this is a bit of a challenge
right because and we should we should
put this unit right what a report on it
is it two significant figures it's
question mark or is it one you're gonna
get sick of ready see new if it is - um
is it what what is it - now because I
told you exactly what that was I told
you it was thirty students those
students in class you guys know it's not
that hard to just actually count up
individuals and you know high school
actually thirty is a very common um why
is thirty copy number because that's the
maximum it's supposed to be anyway so
therefore thirties going to come up what
exactly thirty okay but if you didn't
know that if I just told you the number
they didn't tell you what it was Mary
didn't tell you context didn't tell you
anything all new songs didn't know then
just like at the top of the board you
see all these zeros and you're like well
maybe it was 29 it's a hair roughly
buddy maybe it was 33 and you said yeah
roughly thing so I don't know which one
of those it is if I don't have any
context does that make sense
okay so in this context I can say yeah
that's - because I know that I have
information that provides us - okay but
all I see is a number then I can assume
I can't know if you actually went
individually encounter that zero is the
result that happens when you round so I
have to assume that that's being rounded
if I have no other information does that
make sense
so shy fella if I just told you 24
billion right what do you think of the
chances of us counting up 23 million
nine hundred nine thousand two hundred
ninety eight twenty nine ninety nine
nine it's stopping lying on a dime
actually what do you think of the
chances they're pretty low right they're
pretty low whereas what are the chance
that this was some number that got
rounded and therefore you ended up with
zeros quite oh it's quite high right now
because zero is the number you end up
with after rounding and you don't know
which one it is you have to assume with
no other information that it's being
rounded okay so if then until you I
counted up individual students and they
were exactly 30 on
then that looks to me only one of those
numbers can be significant does that
make sense
correct it doesn't give you all the
information
yes changes yes no okay now I'm always
one say before I get to question it so
you can print here no that's okay I'll
get to you this is tricky records you
guys know all the time in this subject
in particular I'm always kind of doing
two things right I'm trying to make sure
you are really good at this course yeah
but then I'm also trying to make sure
that you are a numerous literate citizen
who can work with numbers in the real
world but you're not being marked and
there's no marking guideline we need to
try to read something and understand
before yourself okay so at this moment
I'm kind of mostly reading the second
half right I need you to be able to look
at numbers in the real world whether
they give you details forward of dollars
and then be able to interpret right when
so assists you yeah okay
the average income the average household
salary in New South Wales raises is
about $135,000
what are you gonna do are you gonna
think hmm
I think I am going to assume they were
only three significant thing is that
right or are you gonna wind up alone no
maybe maybe some exams said I said no
actually there are 60 million figures
that you don't really know that's not
what you're gonna do you're gonna read
them happen you guys think of course
then approximated of course this how
long many number of households and they
just want a round number you know what I
bet I bet that five has also been
rounded okay so my point is you're gonna
see real data and real data in the real
world almost always you know you know
what I'm gonna say always whatever it's
been measured has some kind of rounding
approximation that's been born into it
so you always get super minion feels
okay